it's important as entrepreneurs to keep
trying new things if you keep doing the
same thing over and over and over and
over again you're going to get bored
you're going to get stuck in a rut
you're going to think your business
sucks that your life sucks and you're
not going to know how to get out of it I
was recently inspired by someone who
came to ask me for some salsa lessons I
like to teach salsa as one of my hobbies
and this woman came to me she was
Eastern European tall blond woman wanted
to learn how to salsa her whole life I
never had the courage to actually do it
and so this was the day this was her day
which he was going to learn how to salsa
and she came into the office and i took
her hand and she was shaking trembling
and nervous that she hopes she wouldn't
embarrass herself or you know fear of
failure kicking in and I told her it's
going to be okay you're going to be fine
and it showed her the first move and she
did it
so shoulder more moves and she did those
two and with each move she gained more
confidence the smile came on her face as
she realized that she could do it and
that fear that she had him starting was
unfounded she had this belief that it
was going to be really hard and she
couldn't do it and it wasn't for her she
just wasn't made to be a dancer and now
she was doing it she broke through that
barrier all it took was stepping out on
the ledge a little bit having a little
bit of trust and faith she left that day
feeling like a new person she just
conquered a fear tried something new and
felt happy about her sigh herself in her
life I asked her what she was going to
go do next and she said she's gonna go
by bicycle because she always wanted to
ride a bike so that was her next stop it
was a beautiful day here in Toronto and
I was a little jealous of her getting to
go out and ride a bike and she inspired
me that day because I don't know what
changed in her life that made her want
to try these new things that she had
never done before often it's when we hit
rock bottom that that's when things
force us to change force us to go and
try new things it doesn't have to be
that way you don't have to hate your
life so much that's what drives you to
make a change you can proactively do
things in your life in your business to
experiment learn new things and grow and
when you try something new and you get
it there's an element of excitement
there's a thrill there's a happiness and
that applies to your life but as well as
your business try new things in your
business you're always excited by the
new project right as entrepreneurs we
love the new it still has to make sense
now just go out and spend tons of money
and time on these projects they don't
pan out but at the same time I don't
want you just doing the same thing over
and over and over again and hate
your business those new little passion
projects add energy and add excitement
to your business and you never know
what's going to work out it'll make you
happy entrepreneur and it'll make you
happier person so don't be afraid to
continue to reach out and try new things
good luck if you guys agree you're going
to go try new things you're going to
reach out you're going to keep injecting
excitement and energy into your lives
please give this video a thumbs up it
makes want to do more for you and I'd
love to hear what you have to think if
you want to leave a comment under the
video I always read those each one I see
personally so please leave a comment I
love to hear from you and I'll see you
on the next episode
you